Bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
de Chroniques de Prof,
tout d'abord je tiens à remercier
toutes les personnes qui m'ont félicitée,
encouragée, congratulée, répudiée...
Euh, non, pas répudiée.
Bref, vous avez été très nombreux à apporter des commentaires
positifs et constructifs à ma première vidéo
ce qui explique mon retour ici aujourd'hui !
Alors sans plus attendre, c'est parti pour un nouvel épisode.
Pour cet épisode, j'ai décidé
de taper d'un grand coup de poing sur la table
et de mettre un terme aux idées reçues sur le Moyen-Âge.
Mais d'abord, c'est quoi le Moyen-Âge ?
Les hommes du XIIIe siècle
ne se définissaient pas en disant "Moi, je viens du Moyen-Âge",
comme on pourrait dire "moi, je viens de..."
Le terme a été inventé juste à la période suivante,
la Renaissance, qui commence environ au XVe siècle.
Donc là on a l'idée générale tout de suite,
"Nous sommes la Renaissance, nous brillons par
notre art et notre pensée,
par contre avant c'était très moyen...
C'était plus comme l'Empire Romain qui était évolué,
mais c'était pas encore comme nous...
On va appeler ça le Moyen-Âge. Ils vont pas se plaindre, ils sont déjà morts.
Le Moyen-Âge est aussi une période qui dure environ 1000 ans,
il est donc beaucoup plus long que toutes les périodes qui l'ont suivi.
De ce fait, on ne peut pas le résumer simplement aux
seigneurs et aux châteaux forts.
Il est beaucoup plus complexe, et il y a eu
énormément d'évolutions et d'innovations sur cette période.
Généralement on considère qu'il commence en 476,
c'est à dire à la chute de l'Empire Romain d'Occident.
On peut aussi le faire débuter au baptême de Clovis,
qui a lieu entre 496 et 507,
on n'a pas de sources assez précises pour le savoir.
Contrairement à votre prof de primaire, qui vous affirmait
que c'était en 496 !
Pour la date de fin on a plusieurs possibilités,
la fin de la guerre de Cent Ans en 1453,
ou encore la chute de Constantinople qui a lieu la même année,
la découverte de l'Amérique par Christophe Colomb en 1492,
ou encore la réforme protestante de 1517.
Tous les changements qui amènent à une nouvelle période se font
lentement, les dates de début et de fin sont donc au final assez vagues.
On parle aussi de Haut Moyen-Âge,
pour le début de cette période,
et de bas Moyen-Âge pour ses derniers siècles.
On peut donc dire que le Moyen-Âge connaît des hauts et des bas !
Comme première idée reçue on peut parler du droit de cuissage,
dont vous avez probablement déjà entendu parler,
et dont vous savez peut-être même ce qu'il en est réellement.
Le droit de cuissage est cette idée reçue
qu'au Moyen-Âge, lorsqu'un serf ou un vassal se mariait,
le seigneur avait le droit de profiter de la jeune mariée
le soir de ses noces avant le marié lui-même.
Et vive les mariés !
Allez, je vais récolter mon impôt.
Bien entendu il est très peu probable ue ce droit ait été pratiqué,
et surtout on ne le retrouve dans aucun texte de loi.
Si quelques seigneurs peu sympathiques ont pu profiter de leur statut pour faire ce genre de choses
ce n'était pas approuvé par la loi.
Le droit de cuissage est une invention postérieure au Moyen-Âge,
il apparaît au XVIe siècle,
et il est surtout repris par les Lumières puis après la Révolution Française
Pou dénigrer le système féodal de l'Ancien Régime.
Alors, les enfants.
Je vais lire les idées que vous avez proposées
pour plomber la popularité de nos seigneurs !
Ils nous prenaient tout notre argent par les impôts...
C'est pas possible ça, dans cent ans plus personn n'y croira...
La suite !
Ils fabriquaient des protéines à partir de nos morts
et nous les faisaient manger sans qu'on le sache...
Danton, on a dit plus d'alcool pour toi !
Ils baisent nos femmes...
J'aime bien ça !
C'est simple, ça parle aux gens...
On n'a qu'à dire qu'ils les baisent le soi de leurs noces,
ça ajoute un petit aspect romantico-tragique.
Adopté !
Ce droit est donc repris, commenté, et considéré comme ayant existé
par certains historiens du XIXe siècle,
tels que Jules Michelet, qui est pourtant loin d'être une buse.
On a aussi Jean Florimont Boudon de Saint-Amand,
écrivain, archéologue,
qui en 1818 cite un texte du Moyen-Âge,
soit disant authentique,
mais dont on n'a jamais retrouvé de trace.
"Ici est la carte et statut du droit de primauté et de défleurement
que le seigneur de la terre et seigneurie de Blanquefort
a et doit avoir, blablabla,
toute et chacune les filles non nobles qui se marient en ladite seigneurie
le premier jour des noces.
Donc ce texte existe,
uniquement dans un livre du XIXe siècle.
Le droit de cuissage est aujourd'hui démenti, mais on le retrouve encore
dans la culture populaire, par exemple dans le film Braveheart
où il est employé sous le terme de Prima Noctis.
Alors d'accord, monsieur Wallace, c'est pas cool ce qui arrive à votre femme.
Mais ce qui est encore moins cool, c'est de faire un film sur un personnage qui a existé,
qui a mené une rébellion dont l'importance est immense,
et de donner pour raison à cette rébellion un droit qui n'a jamais existé !
Merde !
Vous êtes qui, vous ?
Euh, bonjour, je viens du Moyen-Âge !
[musique dramatique]
Nous reprenons cette émission en ayant la chance de recevoi une invitée venue du Moyen-Âge.
Ce que je ne m'explique pas.
Mais elle pourra sûrement nous apporter des tas de précisions sur cette période !
Par exemple, raconte nous ta journée ?
Ah, ben, je me suis levée, je me suis lavée...
Tu t'es lavée ? J'en suis fort aise,
car dans le top 15 des bonnes raisons de ne pas vivre a Moyen-Âge de Topito
on raconte que vous ne connaissiez pas l'hygiène.
C'est n'importe quoi, j'adore aller aux bains !
En plus, c'est relaxant.
En effet on imagine à tord l'homme médiéval comme quelqu'un de sale,
qui aurait peur de l'eau,
Mais en réalité se baigner était une pratique courante,
on en est sûrs dès le XIIe siècle grâce aux sources.
Par exemple, à Paris au XIIIe siècle,
on compte 27 étuves, des sortes de bains publics, puisque
tout le monde n'avait pas les moens de se baigner chez soi.
Dans les campagnes on se baigne dans les lacs,
ou dans les rivières, on utilise aussi des plantes
et autres produits naturels
pour se laver les cheveux, se blanchir les dents, etc.
Quand on n'a pas le temps de prendre un bain on effectue une toilette partielle une fois habillé,
du visage et des mains.
On utilise des savons, qui sont souvent un mélange de graisse, de cendre et d'huile,
on mâche des herbes pour avoir bonne haleine...
Bref les gens au Moyen-Âge sont propres,
Et c'est à la Renaissance que les choses vont changer.
Déjà, au XVe siècle, les bains publics
commencent à poser problème, car on les accuse d'être des lieux de débauche
que l'Eglise veut faire fermer.
En plus de cela on commence à les accuser de transmettre rapidement
certaines maladies telles que la peste.
Du coup les bains publics ferment.
D'autant qu'un autre idée commence à se répandre:
on pense que la dilatation des pores,
provoquée par les bains, affaiblit le corps.
Alors qu'une bonne couche de crasse nous protège de toutes les maladies !
Jusqu'à la fin du XVIIIe siècle, les nobles fuient l'eau comme la peste
et sont rapidement imités par le reste de la population.
A la place ils utilisent des parfums,
des cosmétiques... Pour donner l'impression de ne pas trop puer.
A part ça, c'est la Renaissance...
Exactement ! T'as une feuille, là...
Si on parlait des famines, maintenant ?
C'est bien connu, au Moyen-Âge tout le monde meurt de faim !
C'est pas vrai, ce matin j'ai mangé du pain et même qu'après j'avais plus faim du tout.
J'en suis ravie.
Et il est vrai que les périodes de famines sont beaucoup plus rares
qu'on pourrait le croire au Moyen-Âge.
D'abord entre le Ve et le VIIe siècle,
on n'en rencontre que trois.
Ensuite à l'époque carolingienne, on en compte quatre
entre 845 et l'an mil.
De l'an mil à 1350,
les choses se gâtent et on compte en tout onze années de famine.
La population augmente et plus on est de fous, moins y'a de riz.
Au XIVe - XVe siècle, on compte quand même
pas mal de famines à cause du climat qui est plutôt frisquet
et de la guerre de Cent Ans qui n'arrange pas les choses.
Tu me donnes les dates, que je sache quand faire des réserves ?
Bien sûr il y a aussi de nombreuses périodes de disette,
mais on constate que les vraies famines sont plutôt rares.
Ensuite, on a aussi tendance à associer le Moyen-Âge aux maladies, omniprésentes.
Alors oui, il y a de nombreuses maladies au Moyen-Âge,
mais pas toutes à la fois !
La variole disparaît dans la partie Nord de la France
au IXe siècle, la peste bubonique fait des ravages
jusqu'au VIIIe siècle seulement,
ce qui est donc loin de concerner toute la période du Moyen-Âge !
Jamais entendu parler de ces maladies...
La lèpre diminue fortement,
mais réapparaît à partir du XIIe siècle
à cause de nouvelle relations avec le Proche-Orient qui lui est assez touché.
D'ailleurs, tu sais comment on dit bonjour à un lépreux ?
On lui sert la main et on lui rends ?
Non ! On lui dit pas. C'est un paria,
et il a sûrement fait de la sorcellerie pour mériter ça.
Par contre la peste noire, le grand ennemi,
apparaît à partir de 1347 en Europe, avec une première
épidémie qui arrive par la Méditerranée.
Et là c'est une maladie bien efficace,
elle allège la France de 41% de sa population,
ce qui n'est pas négligeable,
elle réapparaît trois fois au XIVe siècle
et douze fois au XVe siècle.
C'est la maladie la plus terrible qu'ait connu le Moyen-Âge,
Mais elle n'apparaît que sur ses deux derniers siècles, sur une période de mille ans.
En gros j'suis née à la pire période possible. Super.
Et on va terminer dans la joie et la bonne humeur sur un thème que tout le monde aime !
La mort.
Si c'est encore déprimant, je rentre chez moi !
Tu peux pas.
On dit souvent qu'ai Moyen-Âge l'espérance de vie était de trente ans, voire moins.
QUOI ?!
C'est vrai, mais on oublie souvent que les enfants sont également comptés dans ce calcul.
Et il est vri que la mortalité infantile est très élevée jusqu'au XVIIIe siècle.
Ce qui fait donc chuter les statistiques, et la vente de biberons.
Tu peux atteindre les 60 ans avec un peu de chance,
C'est tout à fait possible et encore plus si tu es riche.
[Musique: je suis en vie]
Voilà, j'espère que ce nouvel épisode vous a tout autant plu et instruit que le précédent.
Encore une fois n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne, à partager cette vidéo,
Et à me dire ce que vous en avez pensé, j'ai adoré avoir des retours sur le premier épisode.
D'ailleurs s'il y a des sujets que vous voulez que je traite vous pouvez me les suggérer,
J'ai déjà pas mal d'idées en stock mais si le sujet que vous me proposez me plaît
Je pourrai peut-être en faire une vidéo.
Moi j'ai pas le droit d'en proposer...
Merci d'avoir regardé, et à la prochaine !